[Music]
on today's show we talk about what to do
when your child's having nightmares
particularly around family trauma
we talked to a young man who wants to
stop lying they just
can't quit we also talk about
instagram's new program for
kids stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up this is
one this is the dr john dolone show
no it's not called sayamawan it's
mayhema one i just said
what is my name john it's sayamu
john man crushing i have not lived in
texas for several years and you can tell
i hope you're all doing awesome this is
the dr john delony show
if you want to be a part of this show
please give me a call 1-844-693-30
that's one eight four four six nine
three three
two nine one go to johndaloni.com
show and write in the
form tell me what's going on in your
life what's going on with your family
with your friends with your community
all of it
and love to have you on the show
a couple of things one we have a new
segment it's going to be a one-time only
segment
called um adventures
in autocorrect so here's a text that i
sent
um somebody who works with me and they
you consider themselves my boss because
they are
i texted and i quote i was thinking
about joining forces
fill in the blank and it auto-corrected
too
i was thinking about honking horses are
you in
to which my boss said
i i'm not super certain what honking a
horse would be
you can go ahead and count me in just
because i'm down but
you'll have to explain what honking
horses is
i was thinking about joining forces so
that wraps up today's segment
of adventures in autocorrect the second
thing i want to talk about is this
listen we can't get bipartisan support
for breathing if somebody puts forth
a bill that said we want to encourage
humans to breathe the other side
whatever that side would be would put a
bill saying
no we are anti-breathing we are
anti-breath
there will be no breathing on our watch
but leave it to the interwebs to create
bipartisan support for something
so 44 according to this article by mark
pratt and the associated press
44 attorney general's bipartisan support
say what what does this mean is the
world solving itself
it's not but this is kind of awesome a
bipartisan group of 44 attorney generals
has written to facebook ceo mark the
zucks
zuckerberg urging him to drop company
plans for a version of instagram
for children under the age of 13.
i don't have words for that i do for the
bipartisan thing hey whatever guys
whatever works to get you all
together men and women congratulations i
want to applaud
everybody for saying i hate you but this
is ridiculous
i don't have the words for an
instagram for kids i don't know what
about the data
that we see over and over and over about
kids consuming social media
would suggest to a company you know what
we should do we should make one just for
them
it's like making cigarettes for children
right or making like you know we need
beer for kids beer for kids that that's
more focused on
kids maybe it's got a little fruitier
flavor or whatever
holy smokes one of the attorney general
said it's shameful that facebook is
ignoring the very real threat that
social media poses to the safety and
well-being of young children
in an attempt to profit off a vulnerable
segment of our population
oh geez listen good folks
for what for as far as you can see
please cultivate universes where your
kids
interact with real people where they are
bored
or they're frustrated where they have to
go play in
dirt where they have to build stuff out
of scraps of wood
and rocks and glue and old buttons
were they you know what if it came down
to
playing uh on instagram for kids
and smoking cigarettes for kids i would
rather them
go play video games together i seriously
would and y'all if you've been a part of
the show for any more than five minutes
you know i just i'm not a huge fan of
that
but i would i'd rather that man
let your kids exercise go run around
play games give them a stick and a ball
and a tire
and a pony i don't care what it is but
if we can
if our government can decide you know
what let's stop drinking the hatred for
30 seconds and
all write a letter about how stupid and
ill-advised this is
for crying out loud we can too as
parents because at the end of the day
man the government stepping in on our
behalf it's up to us as parents
to not let kids
my friend came and stayed with us this
weekend we had a family come stay with
us a guy i've known for 25 years
kids came and his daughter's in second
grade and she was just talking about all
the tick tock
and smartphones that her friends in
second grade have
and i would say that's insane it's
clinically insane it's not
it's heartbreaking it's wrong that we
have ever put our kids in that position
to create a digital trail
from the age of six seven eight nine
and hand it to a company and say use
this wisely
just as nuts don't leave your kids on
tick tock guys don't let your kids
on social media engage with them
figure something else out okay that's my
little i can't good job
government you're not gonna hear me say
that very often but good job government
way to go way to go
geez louise all right let's uh let's get
right to the calls today let's go
out to tim in tucson arizona
tim what's going on this morning how are
you i'm good dr john how are you
outstanding brother so what's going on
how can i help
so in uh in march my nephew
took his life how old was he man
he was 21. i'm so sorry tim
well i i i really appreciate that um
and since then um my my oldest daughter
has really struggled with this one they
weren't necessarily close
however it's it's it's hit her in a way
that
it's kind of hard to to describe she is
kind of opened up about it and said you
know i i wish i could have done
something i wish i could have prevented
it
and then she then has continued to say
that you know i'm afraid
that possibly i will then take my life
sure
and then i don't know probably maybe a
month ago
she started having these night terrors
and it's been
four or five nights a week where she
just
wakes up with these terrible dreams of
you know him being hurt and she's trying
to save him and she can't
and it's it's just been relentless
yikes man um and so we've we've
uh whoo did i think that was this was
going to be
nice challenging your good brother's
hard man it's hard
in my head i played this conversation
out multiple times and it was way easier
in my head
dude so much you should see when i try
to make a jump shot i'm always going to
make it in my head until i actually let
the ball go and it never
never goes in man so i'm with you hey
there is something
and i appreciate you saying that out
loud there's something
uniquely um um
unique about saying something out loud
and it's hard so i appreciate you doing
that man that's brave brother um
so where does that leave you guys you
and your wife or does that leave your
family right now
so we have um
you know we we've reached out to local
counselors here
okay and either they don't take kids
or they're booked out for
for months and months and or they don't
accept our insurance so it's only
cash pay yep which i mean million
dollars
yeah well i mean and it's not about the
money it's just about the
um i just want to make sure she gets
some quality service so once he ended up
reaching out to the school
and the counselor got in contact with
her and it was great and it was
it was it was working really well
however with
summer approaching yep that ends
you know yeah and i just i'm
i'm at a point where i don't know how i
can help
my daughter because she doesn't
necessarily want to go to another
counselor and
start over you know with with trying to
you know progress but i i'm trying to
see if there's any practical tools
you got it that me and my wife can do to
help her with these
these night terrors that she has man
well i love your heart dude
um yes there are and um there's also
um something you can do with it with the
counseling but
so give me one piece of information how
did she come to find out about this what
was what was your
you and your wife's grieving process
like how did your daughter find out
about it
walk me through that really quick so um
we got the phone call it was early in
the morning um i don't know it's
probably 5 30 in the morning
six in the morning our time so we were
kids were up we were getting
you know ready for the day and so
went into the room but then they told me
hey you know
um he he actually didn't even tell me i
first said he had taken his life he said
he had passed away
um and so immediately me and my for like
well
let's let's see what we can do you know
if i could fly out there because he
lives in wisconsin
okay so that morning
was a little hectic i mean but we we
didn't really
we didn't divulge that information on to
them before going to school
you know we we needed a moment to be
able to kind of
try to process what happened
you know yep and and what what our next
steps were and so
we were as calm as we were we could be
with them i mean the kids could tell
something was off because i was in the
room
sure you know telling them hey stay out
for the time being
um so walk me to that afternoon or that
evening how'd y'all
tell them so i ended up
flying out that afternoon um and
so unfortunately my wife was kind of
left with the badge of kind of
explaining everything okay um and she
had said you know your cousin has passed
away
you know dad went out there to go be
with your uncle
and try to you know help in any way
possible
and immediately my daughter went to did
he kill himself
which right off the bat was like
holy cow we didn't even you know it was
out of the blue you know like why how
did how did your mind even come
to that um you know and so we were like
um well we're not going to lie to you
you
know we're he yes he he he
he did take his life and she wanted to
know why and how
how and we we were like you know we
don't we don't know how or why
at this point and does she know that
stuff right okay
um we we haven't we
we didn't know she he he shot himself
and so we don't
i yeah it's just such a i mean
but you haven't you haven't communicated
that to her right
no we have not i mean we i didn't ask
you how old is she
she's eleven okay all right um and so
go ahead we've explained
you know there's there's you know the
the world is a hard place you know and
and sometimes people feel that's the
only way out and
in those situations we need to look to
to help other people
you know yeah and you never you never
know what a comment you say
could either make or break someone
else's day
and and it's it's it's it's super
fine light of i mean she's still
young but obviously you know this is
something
yeah yeah it's just such a hard place to
be in you know
yep all right so let's let's back out of
here a little bit
and here's what i'm gonna need you to
promise me okay
um i want you to promise me that um i'm
gonna promise you i'm gonna be honest as
i can with you with the best of the
information i got
and i want you to promise me that you
will
look that you will be joyful about
getting new
information and you're not going to walk
back and try to recreate or redo
something that you can't redo
is that cool right okay absolutely
awesome
so anytime i could tell you story after
story after i was well trained
to walk into these situations i would
come back and think
man i absolutely blew that and
um i had a my partner and i would
debrief when i would go into some of
these situations and we would both go in
together and we would talk about hey we
should have said that or you got to ask
this question differently and so
uh i want you to know trained people
still debrief and still say man i wish i
could say this again or that again all
that so
backing all the way up i for an 11 year
old
i would err on the side of this
statement when they ask how did it
happen
why did they do that saying things like
well some people just think that's their
way out some people just choose that
that's how they're going to do this
that is a destabilizing construct for an
11 year old
because the next question they're going
to ask themselves is well what if i'm
that kind of person
or what if i find myself in a situation
where that's the only result
the only thing i can do so my
standard answer for adults and for
children is that they
they were not well they were really
struggling
they were sick there was um a
illness in their heart and in their mind
and
they came to a heartbreaking conclusion
they they did something that they
weren't in their right mind
and that tends to alleviate this idea
that this is
just going around it can happen to
anybody and more
oh okay they were they were sick they
were struggling in that way
also when folks pressed me on details
i would often tell people i want the
last memory you have of that person to
be the last time you saw him
smiling saying goodbye saying i love you
saying i'll see you later
not with whatever imagination imaginary
media filled picture you're going to
concoct in your mind
of what that looks like because unless
you've seen that scene actually with
your own eyes it's not what you think it
is
and so i don't give details especially
like that to children
i might tell them when you get older we
can talk more in details but i want you
to remember
i want you to remember timmy or billy or
whatever his name is um i want you to
remember them
the last time we saw them they were
laughing and smiling before they got
sick
right and so i say things like they died
by suicide
not they committed suicide i want to
norm it that way
in the same way that a kid will be
terrified when somebody they know gets
and dies by cancer
or gets and dies by a heart attack
that's scary because their world
becomes a little bit less stable right
oh that just happens
uh people can get this thing and it ends
this way yes
and so i backing out of this
even another layer is this idea that oh
so let's pause here
so the conversation from this point
forward is
cousin died by suicide he was sick he
was really struggling
and um this is not gonna happen to you
um okay and you can say that with the
period at the end of it
okay and what if i get sick what if i
get like this
we're always gonna be here so if you
ever feel like you're um
that you're not doing well or you're
struggling that's why we're here and
you're going to reach out and we're
going to create a space for you to reach
out
you're always okay to talk to us right
and so what you're trying to do is
you're trying to connect with your
daughter not trying to solve her pain
hurt here
so then i'm going to back out one one
more circle if you will one more
one more i don't know another 10 000
feet here and recognize
that a common response to grief
especially
suicide or especially what people
imagine is a
violent end is their picture of that
person gets stuck
on the violence that they are still
hurting
right right and so a really remarkable
exercise that you as a family could do
together
um you and your wife and your 11 year
old
is to write a letter to him where he is
now right and so if y'all are people of
faith that he's in heaven or if you're
not people of faith that
he is resting gently and he was sick and
he was really struggling
and now he's not hurting right
we wish he was here so much and writing
him a letter
talking about where he might be puts a
new picture in your daughter's head
whether that's in her imagination of
what heaven's gonna look like whether
he's
in a field but it begins to shift
her heart and mind away from this guy's
actively in gruesome pain
right now to oh
he's not hurting anymore we're hurting
right and so she's not stuck on that
that night terror loop of there is
somebody in pain and i can do nothing
about it my body is
fighting and fleeing all at the same
time and it's waking me up and waking me
up and waking me up does that make sense
so that makes sense gives her a new
picture for what that can look like
right
and so um the third thing would be
being really honest with her about mommy
and daddy are sad
and i want you to norm in your house
what those feelings are going to be like
give her permission to if you will have
a release valve so maybe do a nightly
check-in
or not nightly because not doing it
around bedtime is good but an afternoon
check-in
were you thinking about billy today i
was it made me sad
i miss him how did you feel and give her
space give her an invitation to talk
some 11 year olds don't verbalize that
well and so maybe draw on a picture
right um giving her an opportunity are
you all just color together or something
but
create 5 or 10 or 15 or 20 minutes a day
in the afternoon
um or in the morning where y'all can
have some space together just to process
out loud
and let her see you grieving
and let her get a model of what grief
looks like that it's okay i'm not
bananas it's okay to hurt
mommy daddy are sad too and then
recognize her
entire world has shattered in that
right people just die does that make
sense it becomes existential too
um and so writing in that letter letting
her create a new picture and by the way
in that letter you can
she can say i'm really mad at you
that you did this she's allowed to say
that she can be mad at him
it can be heartbroken it can be
um any number of feelings all those
feelings are okay getting them out on
paper gets them out of your head and you
can see them
right and that comes back to one last
important thing that i want to pass
along
um man
you mentioned that um
some people just make this decision i
want you to be really cautious about
giving her weight you never know if you
just say the right thing or the wrong
thing
for an 11 year old every decision just
became life or death
every conversation yeah and so i don't
want an 11 year old walking around
bearing the weight of if i don't say
this thing right to whoever
they may die does that make sense
that that does and i get where your your
heart was awesome
your heart here's my here's my other
thing i tell my son all the day all the
time
you have the opportunity to shine a
light into somebody's day every time you
interact with them
that is a different weight than you
at any moment you could say the wrong
thing and they're gonna die right
that's just gonna yep so one so i would
i would shift that conversation and
maybe even say hey i said this the wrong
way
you are not going to ever be responsible
for somebody taking their life
11 year old child you're not you don't
have that kind of power
right if somebody chooses to take their
life they've got a whole bunch of other
stuff going on
if somebody else dies by suicide there's
so much other
things happening there but what you can
do
is you can make somebody feel loved you
can
shine a light in somebody's soul and so
we in our house
we're going to be about making sure that
the waitress knows that we value her
that that the guy at burger king
we love them that that knucklehead who
keeps driving
too slow in front of us that we're going
to you know we're not going to
yell at them and model for our kids that
we can't control our temper
that is a different way to shift that
conversation than tagging your kid
does that make sense it does and and
that's i mean
over it has definitely that conversation
has shifted in that direction
so what do we have go ahead go ahead no
no please
i'll just say one last thing i would
shift you uh our shift to you is this
about your teacher
ask your school counselor for an a
referral in the city
have you already done that we have um
and we don't live
in tucson where we're like two hours
south so we're in a smaller
community okay and it's they're just
there's not any options here it would it
would have to be going up to tucson to
try to find someone
okay and she she did not know of anyone
there so let's do this we can have some
fun um
you can turn it into a fun conversation
or thing you're going to do as a family
but i want you go to betterhelp.com
ramsay
and if you can't get in person they do
have online counseling they have a
special deal that we've
they worked out for listeners of this
show
and uh oh it's uh it's um
betterhelp.comdelony
and d-e-l-o-n-y and they'll give you a
discount
and on the first month of counseling
there but you and her y'all could talk
to a therapist
you can put it up on your tv screen at
home so she can watch it and be
interacting with it
and you can get some more practical
tools and tips there
but my hunch my gut tells me that you
guys sit down and have these
conversations with her
write him a letter have her imagine
where he is
now that he's not actively hurting
anymore um
have a nighttime routine talk about this
in the daytime not
right before bed so that that's the last
thing she's thinking about
begin to and then more most importantly
model for her what grieving looks like
what healthy grieving looks like
and of course if these night terrors
continue if she starts getting more
anxious you see
weight gain or weight loss you see her
beginning to become a shell of herself
um a hundred percent reach out do what
you got to do
you can do half day intensives there's
all kinds of different programs if
you've got to drive to a new city
start with betterhelp.com but make sure
you are reaching out and a high five to
you guys for reaching out to your school
counselor that's fantastic
um but try those things and then give me
a shout back let me know how those
things go
and i'm really grateful that you are
trying to do right by your daughter
and don't neglect your own grief here
you lost your nephew and that's heart
heartbreaking all right let's take
another call let's go to christopher
in butte montana christopher what's
going on
hi how are you doing today all right
brother how are you
i'm doing all right um thanks for taking
my call you got it man so what's up
okay well um just to probably make
something brief that's
a bit more than brief um ever since i
was a kid i'm 23 now
ever since i was a kid 12 14 um i've
always been
almost too good at talking to people and
that has since probably since i was 14
15 has almost made me a compulsive
liar um and it's
dug its nastiness into my marriage and i
don't really know well i know how to fix
it but i'm scared too if that makes
sense yeah absolutely
and i really just don't know what to do
so that's why i'm calling well dude this
is hard and i've been there
i had the same challenge growing up and
um i watched a an executive
self-destruct with the same problem
and i had a ringside seat too oh this is
what how this ends
and it was almost like a light switch in
my life um
and so i'm grateful that at 23 you're
able to recognize this in yourself and
want to do something about it
um backing up men
why do you believe that this true story
of you christopher
is of less value than this concocted
story that you tell
um that's a deep question
i feel like um i feel like i'm a fairly
smart person
and in a lot of circumstances i know
what the right thing or what i should be
doing
is and at the same time
for some reason maybe laziness maybe
something along those lines i don't do
what that right thing is
but i don't want to admit that if that
makes sense
um so give me an example uh
let's see a really good example this is
one of the big ones that i'm trying to
figure out how to deal with
so my wife and i were going to school
right now um online
and i'll be honest school has not been
my forte
um that were college it's been really
rough
but i haven't figured out how to tell my
wife that
um she's a big believer in making sure
we have a degree
and we're doing fairly well i'm a store
manager
but uh regardless i uh
i guess i'm scared to tell her that if
that makes sense but that's what
that's what i'm told i'm trying to get
to the root here
there's a story that you've been told
and that over time you've adopted and
you tell yourself
that the things that you want to do in
your life
aren't valuable or aren't worth or
aren't
enough and so you create personas that
you are a little bit tougher a little
bit faster you hooked up with a few more
people you
ran a little bit faster than you
actually did you scored a few more
points in this
whatever the things are and because
at some deep level the narrative
that you've adopted is chris what
christopher wants is not good
what christopher wants is less than and
so
you spend your life creating an alt
universe for everybody around you
yeah and then what happens when you're
living an alt
universe you start living multiple art
alt universes
and the only thing that tamps that down
is addiction
and the only thing that tamps that down
is
stimulation somewhere else right and so
when you are
um i'll just use your example right you
can tell me if i'm out to lunch here
you don't like me in school you would
rather not be
you know that your wife really values it
so you miss a class and you miss another
class and then you
don't do super great on assignment and
then you don't tell her and now you got
a secret between you
you planted a seed and it's a secret and
then you've had that weird feeling when
she says how was school and
just you blurt out cool man going great
how's that test
it was good and now that secret you
watered it right and now it's growing up
between you
and then you feel that gap and that
distance and the only thing that makes
that gap in distance
go away it doesn't make it go away not
burn a hole in you
is pornography talking to somebody else
at work that you can be flirty with
another drink another drink
just watching uh episodes after episodes
you start having to fill that gap with
something else because you've
you've created a a gap in the
relationship am i
am i onto something am i right yeah
okay if you are okay um not that i've
lived this but i'm just saying right
so here's what you've got to do there's
only one way through this and you know
what it is
right but it's it's you think you know
what it is but you actually don't it's
gonna be a little bit different
first and foremost you got to come clean
on
all of it and the the story you just
told me about school
is the most sanitized one of these
things am i right
yeah okay what's the one giant
um thing that you're holding on to that
you haven't told her
um well i there's two okay
and one is sort of a root of all of this
but the first big
one is i it's school related i've
basically i'm on the verge of getting
kicked out
and the second one is pornography
related um
ding ding okay yeah and
did you cheat on her when y'all were
dating no
that is one line i've never crossed
fortunately all right good
um all right so here's what we're gonna
do you're gonna um
have that conversation with him you're
gonna let her know it's coming okay
and you're gonna tell hey we have to
talk about some hard things and so i
want you to clear your schedule
and um it's gonna be a couple hours
and i've got some stuff i need to talk
to you about number one she's probably
gonna know more about this than you
think she does
occasionally people are totally
blindsided but often not
um and then number two before you have
that conversation
you've gotta get with a male friend of
yours
a guy friend and tell him everything
all of it and you have to commit
to somebody not your wife
that this is the last dishonest thing
you ever say and or do
period okay
the only way forward is um
to keep a sentence in mind that a a
mentor of mine
told me his name is randy harris and he
said the greatest question anybody can
ever ask themselves is this
is integrity something you can sort of
have
is integrity something you can mostly
have
and i don't draw a lot of hard lines but
i do draw a hard line about that
because dishonesty and stealing destroys
people and if you just tell your
this to your wife you are too smart and
too quick
and you will wrap this up and she wants
so hard to believe in you
that she will buy whatever box of crap
you're trying to sell her
and you know that and i know that so
you've got to bring somebody else into
this conversation that's going to hold
you accountable
it'd be really cool if it was your dad
or if it was her dad or somebody
of high importance that you really want
their approval you really want them to
speak in your life but my guess is one
or both of those men probably contribute
to this challenge so that might not be
best
if you've got a spiritual mentor that
you trust if you've got um an older
wiser gentleman that you trust an old
college professor somebody that will
speak into your life and will call you
regularly
and say are you still telling the truth
right
or that when you do slip up and lie you
can let them know how i screwed up today
almost like an aaa meeting
now are you actually going to do that or
no no that actually sounds like
something
i want to do i don't know really how to
explain it but and i mean maybe you
have heard this or can understand it but
it just it's a lot
to yes it's like i'm always worrying
about it you know
yes it's weird i've never talked about
this out loud so this is a
lot yes it it's a ton right and you will
um you'll feel better after this call
you'll feel better after this call you
will know um
because here's the thing you're carrying
around a sack full of bricks man all the
lies but beneath the lies
is this narrative that what i want and
what i value doesn't matter
and so i've got to keep everybody around
me happy and the way i keep them happy
is by
giving them all stories of different
versions of myself
you got to stop today
i will never lie i'll never steal again
and when i
slip up on one of those i'm gonna go to
the ends of the earth to make it right
to call it out
to be over the top about it okay i
appreciate your bravery christopher
today's the day here's what i want you
to do i want you to um
make that declaration today call
somebody today talk to him about it and
then
let your wife know we're going to meet
this weekend we need to have some direct
conversations
and by the way don't flunk out of school
don't flunk out of school there's no
professor on earth that wants to flunk
you out of school
that's you deciding i'm going to make a
statement don't do that
at the very least go to your professors
and say hey i need to take a
incomplete i need to talk about this i
haven't been doing my work
but don't choose to flunk out of school
man that's choosing to take those bricks
out of your backpack and just hit
yourself in the head with it that's
that's
a waste of time all right so you're on
it down you're on the
america's clock the dishonesty stops
today right all right everybody we'll be
right back
stay tuned on the dr john dolone show
[Music]
hey before you skip over this listen i
know that sometimes we try to sell you
stuff on here during these breaks
but today i'm gonna flip that around and
give you an opportunity to win
cash not really cash amazon gift cards
but same thing right
listen we're the most surveyed group of
people
ever in the history of the world and i'm
beat down by
surveys just like you right you go to a
drive-through
and you just want to get a burger and
fries and some weird diseases
all on your own and then by the time you
drive through they're texting you
hey will you answer five questions about
no no i just want my burger right
i get that surveys are super lame
so here i come at you with a survey but
here's the deal here's the deal
this show has always been for you about
you
and you are critical to what we're doing
here right
so we're doing our very first listener
survey for this show
please don't roll your eyes i know i
know i know but listen i want to hear
what you enjoy
what you don't enjoy i want to hear what
you want to hear more of in each episode
do you want more interviews more callers
any specialized topics teaching segments
plus we've got to get to the bottom of
whether we need more horse noises or not
right what guitar is the best all that
stuff
i want to hear from you right so text
the word
survey to 33789 to take the survey
and i'll enter you in a chance to win a
50 amazon gift card
that's survey s-u-r-v-e-y to-33789
just text that and it closes on friday
july 9th so do it today
i want to hear from you
all right we're going to take an email
here from kevin
uh this is kevin is is the guy that
we're using here but i get this email a
lot so i want to take a moment to
talk about this i he kevin writes i hear
you use the word season when describing
a time of life that somebody is in
my buddy todd hates it when i say hey
it's just a season he
drives him crazy and that makes me happy
kevin asks
what constitutes a season what is the
time frame
here's the time frame whenever you want
whatever it's going to take for you
to get to the end of whatever you're in
the middle of
right that sounds really vague and it
kind of is here's the key to
identifying seasons it's this one magic
word
intentionality here's an idea
or here's an example um i'm going to be
i'm going to go on a new weight loss
program
i want to get my health back and i'm
going to meet with a weight loss coach a
nutritionist or with a doctor or with a
local trainer whatever the thing is
i know for a season my life's gonna be
really uncomfortable until my body
adjusts
until it makes its move right or i'm
starting grad school
i'm gonna sit down with my wife and say
this is a two-year program or it's a
doctoral it's a four or
five or six year program what does that
mean for us that means
weekends are gonna be hard to come by
we're gonna have to intentionally
schedule date nights we're gonna have to
intentionally schedule time with the
kids
we're just gonna have to be intentional
about this that means
on weekends she's gonna have to be
intentional about spending time with
other friends
that because i'm not gonna be there we
may have to intentionally
um find someone to take care of the yard
whatever that happens to
be it's just recognizing and calling out
the season
right here's here here's where that
metaphor comes from
we don't say when summer rolls into fall
and into winter we don't say that
summer's broken
it's not it naturally moves to winter
and it's a season when things are really
cold it's annoying it's freezing you
gotta wear
coats and you can't just run outside and
whatever same kind of thing
all right so in a season of grad school
in a season of new job
in a season of somebody's pregnant or we
have a two-year-old and a one-year-old
and now we're
she my wife's pregnant whatever that is
and we're in a season of chaos that's
okay
it's knowing it's not gonna be this way
forever but it's just that we right now
and we're gonna plan accordingly to
right now
remember when you were a little kid in
the in the basketball coach said
we're gonna run a hundred laps you could
do that
because you knew the number what you
couldn't do is when the coach said
we're gonna run till i get tired
watching you i would rather
run 50 laps knowing i'm gonna run 50
then run 20 laps and not ever have a
guess
right and the coach just keeps blowing
that whistle go again go again
go again right he's making you tough
making me crazy
right so a season is just identifying
here is the time period
here's the stressors we're going to be
under let's call them out let's put them
on the table
let's put them on the calendar let's put
them in the budget let's put them in our
hearts and minds
and let's plan accordingly and then
we're gonna plan a big celebration
right disney world's at the end of this
thing or the movies or ice cream or
whatever the thing is
is at the end of this thing and we're
gonna mark it as a season right
that's all that means so you decide when
you're going to be intentional and how
you're going to be intentional and what
that's going to look like
thank you for the question kevin so
grateful that you asked
um if you have more questions like that
man
ask john ramseysolutions.com send them
in and we'd love to hear from you
all right as we wrap up today's show i'm
gonna actually start rolling in
um we're about 130 140 shows in
let me start getting into my heart a
little bit these are songs that actually
are my favorites of my favorites
throughout the last 120 130 shows i have
sprinkled in some of my real favorites
the next couple of shows here's some
actual real favorites
this is off the 1982 nebraska album one
of the greatest records ever made
i don't have it up sometimes i even have
it up here kelly's booing me boo
[Music]
it's highway patrolman by bruce
springsteen he writes my name is joe
roberts and i work for the state i'm a
sergeant out of
perrinville barracks number eight i
always done an honest job as honest as i
could
i got a brother named frankie and
frankie ain't no good
yeah me and frankie laughing and
drinking and nothing feels better than
blood on blood
taking turns dancing with maria as the
band played night
of the jonestown flood john's down flood
i catch him when he's straying like any
brother would
man turns his back on his family he just
ain't no good
stop what you're doing and go listen to
that song put some headphones on and
listen to the words
if you don't have a tear in your eyes
you should probably go see somebody this
has been the dr john dolone's show
[Music]
you